ein bisschen den suchbildern raff kamera
findet man auf dem bild nicht ein aber
rafft bei punkt null findet man ein
bisschen zwischen zwischen kissen ein
neues album ist am start
bis zum start was sie hoch zwei kraft
3.0 und hoch 2 hat etwas miteinander zu
tun also muss man drei hoch zwei nehmen
und hat neun oder das ding ist halt ich
bin sehr sehr schlecht den albumtitel
finden ok ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
habe bis jetzt noch keinen einzigen
guten albumtitel gefunden ich habe drei
vier fünf alben 45 mixtapes gemacht und
jeder albumtitel was scheiße okay war
therapie vor dem album therapie nach dem
album therapie nach dem therapie ist
dass das war seit meiner titel und 830
dies mein letztes album und ich wollte
einfach den zweiten teil dazu machen und
dachte mir zuteil zweites klingt so
abgedroschen wenn ich einfach hoch zwei
okay sozusagen ein bisschen ansage also
hoch zweimal macht alles noch mal besser
nochmal kraft es ist ihr gelungen
soll man ja nicht von sich selber sagen
so ja ich bin super boy aber mir gefällt
es sehr gut also die fans finden ist
auch super bis jetzt also ich bin
zufrieden sein
wann hat das erste instrument gelernt
mit 44
das war die geigerin ok und wie lange
hast du gelernt vier jahre ca das
klavier hat die gerne abgelöst da war
ich aber schon 66 euro und damit sechs
bis ich quasi bisher zu also bis ich 18
war wirklich klassische ausbildung von 6
bis 18
die gitarre ist dazu gekommen sind und
dann ganz okay und dann wird man
irgendwie multiinstrumentalist würde ich
jetzt gemein fragen wieso repsol wenn du
doch musiker bist naja instrument ist
ein instrument oder rappen alle die gern
instrument beherrschen achter
also sagen wir mal so retten so dass es
sich für einen laien wie web anhört kann
jeder
also nein ich gehe es gibt eine auswahl
ausnahme
mörder mörder hat sich als fan von würde
das triple diesem kumpel wird
ich fühl dich gut hört sich alles
anleihen hört sich ja vieles wenn sich
jetzt ein typ der hinstellt und einfach
sagte ich will am blog do rock gehört
sich dass wir in leinach werbefenster
zeit kennen wird man ab wann wird rap ab
wann wird's happig man im endeffekt
jetzt 2013 ist inzwischen alles schon
wenn man sich nicki minaj an hat sie
auch eine rapperin was die datei version
macht das für mich ganz genau das
gleiche wie damals
ich glaube ich ist ein akku mit war
ideal das ungefähr genau das gleiche
damals war das kein rap jetzt website
aber ich bin sehr froh darüber muss ich
sagen also web hat sich auf jeden fall
geöffnet
du hast heutzutage sehr sehr viele stile
im rap ganz halt auch nicht zu klar
definieren aber natürlich von der wurzel
her ist es sprechgesang sozusagen man
verpackt entsprechenden menschen mit
reimen in eine breite hose und dann hast
du aber mehr oder weniger kunstvoll
natürlich also es ist kunst kunst kommt
von können solange einer wirklich retten
kann ist es kunst wenn ihr nicht warten
kann es ist blödsinn
ok dann hätte man das schon mal klar
gestellt und du bist jemand wenn ich dir
zu hören das geht ja auch sehr in
richtung wirklich musik gesang ist
fertig waren sich wichtig ja oder also
die musik natürlich ist die melodie mir
sehr sehr gut und das ist eine melodie
hat in das stimme aber ich höre privat
also jetzt von meinem privaten tura und
das mit viel gesang nicht mehr so
niederrhein die jungs aber was mir
wichtig ist ist das echt klingt was
wovon ich das kotzen bekomme ist zum
beispiel wenn ich mir leute an die dazu
deutschland sucht den superstar gehen
und zuerst eine wunderschöne stimme
haben und hinkommen eine schöne natur
stimme dann kommen in welche coaches die
sagen nee mach mal so und und übertreibt
das tremolo das vibrato und danach
kommen sie zurück mit einer vollkommen
überspielten perfekten plastik stimmen
sodass das ist nicht nur der gesang das
ist nicht alles so die melodie und dass
jemand gut singen kann er sogar das teil
sozusagen und das haste dir immer
bewahrt deinen style also bisher auch
nicht zu einem major label gegangen
sondern ganz bewusst also gesagt ich
mache mein eigenes ding klar weil ich
will nicht verbogen werden
ich war schon mal beim menschen also ich
war als 18-jähriger war ich in einer
gruppe will man so ein bisschen die
straßen culcha candela her okay ich habe
damals französischen regel gemacht
wie gesagt waren damals bei der mx1 und
ich habe heute einfach gesehen wie das
auch mit 50 oder 100 leuten in einer
etage nicht laufen kann wie das einfach
so ist dass sich jeder kümmert aber im
endeffekt niemand was macht und jetzt
habe ich mein eigenes label mit meinem
partner ronny boldt und meinen besten
freund hamoudi und noch einen weiteren
mitarbeiter und wir haben zusammen mit
abi also wir haben so sagen quasi da so
eine kooperation
aber wir stehen für uns wir machen unser
ding und haben das google namen
sozusagen wieder für mich und ruder in
der hand heißt ja bei dir auch du machst
es etwas anders als vielleicht der
anderen rapper ti sind in der großstadt
im studio du gehst aber ganz weit weg
jetzt klappt in malaga zu früher war ich
natürlich auch beeinflusst von der
großen ich bin ein hauptstadt kind und
jetzt ist es so ich suche die uhr
natürlich ja und vor allem noch mal in
ruhe rappen also im wahrsten sinne freut
ist kann man in ruhe ruhe ja sonst so
ins außenrum ruhig ist kann man da
überhaupt rappen kaufmann nicht das
großstadt viega das ist eine sehr gute
frage die du mir darstellst das eine
sehr gute frage weil diesmal fliege ich
nach barcelona genau ein album
mein vater mich gefragt wieso in basel
bleibt auch gleich in berlin
wieso denn je doch noch mal nach
süditalien irgendwohin wo niemand ist
und ich meinte nein ich brauche das ich
muss auf die straße gehen ich brauche
ein bisschen das urbane das stimmt schon
aber die letzten malaga sessions also
das was wir immer machen ist die songs
aus produzieren sonst lernen und dazu da
dürfen wir nicht abgelenkt werden es
wirklich hohe konzentration das ist sehr
sehr anstrengend das ist quasi arbeit
und totales ausruhen wieder arbeit und
totales aus und das findet man halt denn
wenn es ganz wenn es ganz ruhig ist das
ist quasi die produktionsphase zum
schreiben und für die inspiration
brauche ich die stadt was bedeutet ruhe
fällig der ruhr heißt auf die natur
haben naja also wenn du in ruhe bis wenn
ich in einem raum bin wenn es hier ruhig
wäre würde ich trotzdem die autos hören
würde kein vor gehören vielleicht ein
bisschen wind aber im endeffekt ist das
keine totale ruhe
die ruhe ist für mich wie gesagt wenn
ich das meer wenn ich bäume etwas was
wirklich die die ruhe der natur wie sie
wie sie lebt sozusagen das mit der musik
zusammen
wie meinst du dass die musik sehr
entstanden aus naturgeräuschen die musik
ist ja daraus entstanden das die sag mal
auf dem baumstamm geklopft hatte und da
haben sich bestimmte haben sich die
kantone haben sich ja daraus ergeben hat
das was du damit zu tun dass man
eigentlich gute musik vielleicht nur in
der natur machen kann glaube ich nicht
also ich glaube nicht dass eine schöne
theorie
ich glaube also ich denke nicht also das
ding ist ja man wird ja immer
vielfältiger früher hatte man sozusagen
ein baumstamm wo man drauf klopp danach
kam eine flöte nach der flöte kam dann
irgendwann das erste zupfinstrument und
so weiter und das hatte dann vierter
oder fünfter
dann kam die ersten klavier dann hatte
man endlich zwölf töne dann kamen die
orientalen haben uns viertel töne
gebrauchen
das dann hat man ganz ganz viele tolle
und jetzt inzwischen hat man jeden ton
schon durch also es gibt keine melodien
auf dieser erde die nicht schon mal
gespielt dass ich lasse es werden immer
wieder neue melodien wie war weil es
immer wieder also du hast ja du hast
unterschiedliche tonarten du hast
unendlich viel ton kombination ist du
kannst ja in den du kannst oktav sprünge
machen
du kannst ein unterschiedliches tempo
ganz ganz schnell spielen dann wieder
langsam das hat wirklich alle melodien
waren schalter prozent sich also gucken
und wir haben zwölf töne wir haben nicht
mehr als 12.000 egal in welcher tonart
egal ob du jetzt quasi das c1 oder das
c4 spiels das in vier oktaven
unterschied
ja es ist der gleiche der gleiche tun
was man und du hast nur zwölfter
sgs will heute mit dem könnte man die
musiktheorie gehen aber nur zwölf töne
und diese zwölf töne zu kombinieren das
hat rechnerisch würde sagen wieso wenn
eine band sich vornimmt mit allen tönen
alben zu machen würden die fünf alben
machen dann wäre jeder ton schon
verbraucht
also man hat schon damals hinter in der
klassischen musik einfach so themen
gehört die einfach schon mal verwendet
wurden so wie man jetzt website die auch
schon verwendet wurden sozusagen das
halte man kann sich nie neu erfinden
aber was halt jetzt dazugekommen ist
etwas wunderschönes ist es gibt
unendlich viele sounds ja okay das ist
gerade und dubstep ist zum beispiel wie
einfach sounds also wirklich ja
allerdings deshalb das problem damit hat
nur einen sound soll ein anderes gehört
er habe jobs der patriarchin ein
rückwärts und vorwärts
es hat halt diese babbel basso was du wo
man halt ich mein okay ich bin dabei
das ist halt aber dubstep ist für mich
halt dieser bombenbastler
charakteristisch dann wie du die duos
wie damals die metal bands und so und ja
wie gesagt macht heute halt musik mit
sound ist nicht mehr wirklich die
melodie
zähl ich dort immer die ganzen radiohits
meistens singt jemand drüber weise auf
einem turm
das heißt weil weil es eben auf diese
was ich am anfang schon erwähnt aber es
komme nicht darauf an wie gut du singst
wie gut an texten videos über bringst du
quasi leute sich mit ihr identifizieren
können und ob das gefühl stimmt das wort
es ich hasse zu sagen wenn es für mich
richtig behindert klingt ja weil aber
der wald muss passen von gamezone es
halt wirklich so sagt man glaube ich der
floh auch in der flo ist aber es ist was
anderes der floh den ball zu tun aber
wenn man einen guten flow hat hat man
dann nicht automatisch einen guten wein
ist okay aber keiner redet wieder
scheiße also es kam es kann der beste
floh der welt kommen sozusagen und wenn
einen beschissenen warten bis unterhalb
der barriere passt mit der weit ist das
charisma oder der wald ist das gefühl
die die atmosphäre
ok also jetzt ich will nicht einfach
irgendwelche mittel zu kommen aber ich
habe die landesstraßen partie das ganze
jahr über bringt so das heißt es ist ein
riesen irrtum dass wenn man bei dsds zum
beispiel gewinnt eine hervorragende
stimme hat in irgendeiner weise eine
chance hat weil einem so viele dinge
fehlen die man noch braucht ja man kann
also kann beides also wie gesagt ich
hatte einmal eine große diskussion mit
einem mann der einen musiktheorie buch
geschrieben hat nämlich die hypo formel
und der schreibt in diesem buch so und
so macht man den perfekten hip hop is ok
und so baut man ein hit und dann noch
klangbeispiele und so weiter und ich war
damals noch ein sehr junger produzent
unter produzent von einem prozent
negativen damals und kamen ins studio
merten hey du hast nicht recht das
stimmt nicht und dann am werden gefangen
zu diskutieren und ich meinte zu ihm so
im endeffekt
natürlich sind alle haben gleich
natürlich kann man das so sagen aber das
hat nichts damit zu tun
das muss nicht sein man kann ja mit fünf
gitarrenakkorden sehr sehr viele
welthits ich glaube alle oder wird auch
nahezu alle genau aber wenn ich mich
jetzt hinsetzen um diese fünf akkorde
spiele um das andere dinge muss das kein
welthit
das stimmt natürlich so der beschluss
des kreisausschusses genauso wie jeder
typ der auf heroin ist hat schon mal
gras geraucht aber nicht jeder der gras
raucht nimmt an erinnern
das wäre genug wieder wird das wieder
was gelernt
denn wenn die ruhe so viel bedeutet wie
kommst du oder oder so es gibt die
beiden pole bei dir ruhe und es gibt den
anderen pol gebraucht als inspiration
auch großstadt
was ist das für eine zeit für dich ist
sie die zu hektisch oder ist es genau
die richtige hektik die welt sein 2013
2016 2609 2013
wir können darüber 2016 2016 ist für
mich ein bisschen die hektik ist mir
nicht 1316 jetzt schon 2013
2013 ist mir die hektik nicht menschlich
genug ein bisschen er will nämlich 1996
stand ich vor meinem verstärker mit
marshall verstärkern mit einer gitarre
und aus dem fenster geguckt in wien
fünfhaus und sagt die leute auf den
straßen herum rennen dachte mir bitte
lass es nie ein anderes jahr als 1996
seinen bitte lasten ein anderes jahr
sein und heute 2013 finde ich halt
tatsächlich so ich meine du gehst durch
die durch die klubs durch die bars und
so gucken bei flirt wäre es flirt in der
umgebung wie blablabla das passiert mir
ein bisschen zu viel so also früher war
das wirklich so dass die leute sich auf
die anderen leute konzentriert haben und
das gab dann einen anderen eine andere
art von stress es gab mehr straßenmusik
es gab mehr verrückte sachen die leute
auf der straße gemacht haben so einfach
um sich um sich
irgendwas besonderes dazu bieten will
heutzutage wenig action brauche gehe ich
auf mein iphone und gucke mir
irgendwelche japaner an die kastanien
auf irgendwelche frauen schießen
deshalb wird uns heute ein video
eingeschickt offen will christian huber
also wechselte war für dich eine
traumzeit oder 96 versuche ich meine ich
war sehr jung ich war 12 aber es war auf
jeden fall eine super zeit haben wir ja
ich weiß ich kann ja auch den siebzigern
etwas sehr schönes
es war auch das war lange vor panik ich
habe mir dass unsere dokumentation wird
charles manson reingeguckt das ist ein
massenmörder
das war jetzt nicht so schön aber es
schon möchte man es manchmal abgestellt
haben die hektik so viel also ich finde
sie einerseits ein traum du kannst was
machen und sofort hast du leute die mit
dir interagieren oder tun und
andererseits auch so genau instagram
aber gerade darüber geredet im vorfeld
aktivposten bild und schon strömen die
likes nur so drauf aber andererseits
möchte man auch für sich seine man die
ruhe haben hast du also ist er wenn du
ein mann bist oder anders gefragt wenn
du auf malaga bis auf oder in málaga an
um ihn mit dem umland im umland von
einer gewissen logik
also wenn du um malaga bis das wollte
ich jetzt sagen ohne vergnügen wie genau
wie lange brauchst du um dann die hohe
zu bekommen also im ruhigen zu werden
kommt drauf an
kommt drauf an also das ding ist es
kommt darauf an wie man hingekommen ist
ja also ein paar tage manchmal
vielleicht eine woche und es kommt halt
drauf haben wie sehr man dieses kleinen
diesen kleinen teufel bedient man
einfach kontakte des mit der welt ist
eigentlich keinen unterschied macht ob
man in berlin sitzt oder in malaga also
man muss das handy ausmachen muss zum
strand gehen man muss man wirklich paar
tage runter kommen dann ist er da und
masse dann aus oder was machst du dann
also es kommt halt darauf an es kommt
wirklich darauf an wenn
wenn es nicht geht dann geht es nicht
wenn es geht dann sehr sehr gerne ok
also ich bin überhaupt kein allein davon
wenn ich esse ich mein handy ab ein
beispiel oder wenn ich pro kabine was du
tun handy ab weil im endeffekt das ist
wirklich nervig anderem geburtstag
bist du bist du dich ein bisschen
zerrissen ja was wäre ein wunschtraum
nicht zu wissen zu sagen okay zwischen
was bist du am meisten zerrissen
ich bin am meisten zerrissen ersten
zwischen städte länder welche die ganze
umfahren bin ich mich war vor zwei tagen
noch in wien gestern berlin heute hier
dann ganze zeit unterwegs sondern wie
sender reise jeden tag woanders
ich selbst bin dort geboren dann dort
aufgewachsen dann weiter dort wurzeln
dort wissen meine freundeskreise sind
überall und meine musik ist zu wissen
ich hab' ich mache hip hop mit reggae
einfluss mit grunge einfluss spielen das
mit einer band es ist alles zu wissen
als verwurzeln ich habe wurzeln
aber was sind deine blätter in erpel
also zur hälfte in süditalien zur hälfte
in
vorarlberg südtirol dort direkt über den
alpen sehr schön das kind im urlaub also
leider habe ich halt mit der der seite
sehr wenig zu tun also ich bin mit der
italienischen seite aufgewachsen
sozusagen und frank frankreich wo er
genau in der französischen schweiz bin
ich gebaut und die ersten sechs jahre
aufgewachsen also meine muttersprache
ist französisch da kam ich nach wien in
den fünfzehnten bezirk habe dort meine
bosnischen freunde kennengelernt
denn dann aufgewachsen in kleinen dosen
sozusagen und dann nach berlin
aber button nicht kannst du nicht was
ist kann ich nicht aber ich verstehe und
es gab eine zeitgleich wirklich muss
sich recht gut verstanden habe jetzt
inzwischen sieben jahre in deutschland
leider nicht mehr so denn mit dem wenn
du sagst du bist es nur bis zerrissen
es sind alle möglichen wie sind deine
menschlichen beziehung die auch
zerrissen ist es auch schwierig für dich
oder erleichtert einem dass sogar diese
benennt man das weltenburger fachbegriff
für warte meinen sekunden heißen der
kosmopolit ja genau zerrissenheit also
oder also ist mal einerseits zerrissen
kann man keine freundschaften aufbauen
fällt es schwer oder als kosmopolit ist
es quasi geradezu einfach zu vielen
menschen jung aufzubauen genau
beziehungen auf es war also beziehungen
freundschaft hat die eine sache planungs
die anderen also ich hab zwei
freundeskreise die sehr fest sind also
ich habe meine leute in wien mit dem ich
noch immer seit 15 jahren befreundet bin
in berlin meine engen freunde die ich
seit dem ersten tag sowie caddy
produzent dj und so dass meine leute mit
denen ich auch wissen das macht dich
jeden tag die kenne ich seit sieben
jahre und dann habe ich meine familie in
italien die halt auch fest ist also
sozusagen
jetzt würde ich will das hört sich an
als wären sie sind fest ja also das ist
besser ist wenn man wenn man einer
allgemein also man kann sich jeder
mensch anders was du es gibt leute die
haben kleine richtig guten festen räume
wo die ihr ganzes leben in einer stadt
wohnen
bei mir ist halt so ich habe gott sei
dank wirklich leute auf die ich mich
verlassen kann
eine sehr starke familienzusammenhalt
also meine familie ist unser trainer das
ist sehr schön du bist glücklich
oder ist diese zerrissenheit etwas was
ich auch unglücklich macht ich bin von
natur aus ich bin ein anonymer
melancholie melancholiker ok und eine
selbsthilfegruppe ja bei mir selbst okay
man klavier mit meinem spiel
leute ich mir selbst vor ist auf jeden
fall ich bin natürlich bin so ein typ
ich bin innerlich bin ich sehr
wenn man mal musik hört kann wenn man
kroos musik und meine musik vergleicht
wird man schon sehen wer von uns besser
drauf wenn glücklicheres herz so zu
sagen so ich also bei der es ein
bisschen schwereren als bei mir ist auf
jeden fall sehr viel drin
sehr viel schwerer also das was in
deinen texten vorkommt das ist auch bei
dir das ist unsere prozentig wer also
ich habe eine sehr sehr starke dunkle
seite die man mit einem lachen immer
wieder gut gerne mit dem man gut leben
können was willst du hier
ich wünsche mir die ruhe so zu sagen ich
wünsche mir eines tages eine wohnung in
berlin einen ein haus in süditalien ein
studio im keller eine familie und mein
label das bis dahin vielleicht größer
als manches menschenleben
aber man muss ja hochschießen damit man
ungefähr in die richtung gehen wenn du
stirbst auf was möchtest du
zurückschauen auf leute die rundherum
stehen um diesen sack und nicht aus wie
sagt man aus höflichkeit hinkommen um
sich sehen zu lassen sondern hinzu
kommen für mich zu trauern
da möchte ich darauf zurück schon auf
leute die wenig was gebracht habe und
die mich geliebt haben die ich liebe
du möchtest quasi aus gutem grund
vermisst werden
ich möchte auch so dass ich möchte auch
so
ich möchte auf jeden fall dass wenn ich
von dieser welt gehen egal in welche
richtung das ist etwas gibt es von mir
unendlich hält also ich möchte nicht
dass die welt sich weiterdreht danach
werde ich zu schrauben und weiß nicht
mehr wem möchtest du ein stück haben ein
titel der quasi im gedächtnis von ganz
vielen menschen hängen sehr gerne hatte
den schatz im kleinen kreis kommt opfern
wusste kosmos ist aber in meinem kosmos
auf jeden fall okay was ist dann was ist
dein lieblings was ist denn der rote der
der zum beispiel roboter kann sehr viel
von mir und jetzt ein song für die nbn
ich habe sorgen für den 1
wieder ein bier die offizielle
amerikanische dem deutschen sollte
wie kann unten ist das eine echte und
für jeden tag zwischen den endspielen
nein nein auf deutsch-deutsche
herzlichen kannst du das engagieren
der werbespot kannst du ja gucken voll
wird muss sich überhaupt nicht gut ich
habe ja auch keine anlagen ein das
wussten also ich wusste es nicht bis zu
dem tag wo mein ex label man mich anruft
und ande sollte ich mal aufwecken ist
das und das und warum glaube ich also
die haben mir wurde es nur nicht gesagt
also mein manager hat mir nicht gesagt
weil er gesagt hat ich wollte es dir
noch nicht sagen so lange es nicht
wirklich fix ist okay wird es gab
zwischen universe also meinem verlag
sozusagen dann werden die diskussionen
glauben ist ein jahr
da schlägt das herz das schlägt es hier
in meinem blog gut da wünsche ich ihr
etwas noch oft passiert dass es noch oft
hören
du deinen wunschtraum immer nahe bist so
schön danke dir danke schön